you're
thank you
okay so what I'm not even gonna talk
about all that this part is not
necessary I'm just gonna talk very
briefly about if you had a dataset and
you had to estimate some kind of
estimated mechanism that guarantees a
specific kind of leakage how do you do
that okay
so and I'm going to give you in the vein
of you know large deviation sample
complexity notes so this is joint work
again with some amazing people Mario
Diaz is a was a joint poster code for
Flavio and me he's now back at CIMMYT
awesome awesome mathematician I learned
a lot from him how is a flower student
of course this flower yeah right so the
just just to get you a sense of what the
problem setting is we're so going to
look at a data set where you have a very
clear idea of what the sensitive data is
and the rest of the data needs to be
published okay and you and you get these
parts in this day you get this data you
get n samples and you're going to figure
out how to design a mechanism right so
guarantees from finite samples okay so
here's our formulation today it's X yes
sir yes yes sir it was you so s is a
sensitive variable and there's X which
is correlated with s and nature
determines this joint distribution right
and what we want to find is a mechanism
W that X can be mapped to okay so W is
our privacy mechanism and okay sometimes
we want these Thanks all right
so by chosen by design what we can
choose as a measure of leakage okay so
for the stock and also you can choose
utility I'm not going to talk about
utility I'm just going to talk about
leakage measures right so ignore this
question terrible question not at all
you so here's the question of interest
you give me a data set the first simple
thing I can touch is really hard to do
but I can estimate a distribution on the
datas
right given that distribution I can pick
some privacy mechanism right pick at
random for this distribution which means
I know the cardinality of this sir I
know the cardinality of this set I'm
going to find a mapping let's assume
everything is discrete okay now the
question is if I knew P and I solved an
optimization problem like Aaron wrote on
the board I can determine the actual
mechanism which is a transition matrix
right how would the guarantees differ if
I estimated P versus find new P it's not
so hard to see where I'm going here
right so this sort of leads to how can
you find these things so the there's
really I want to walk to words
maximal alpha leakage and therefore
maximum leakage but I'm gonna go little
steps so I start with off a leakage
which I did not put on the board so you
may not remember but it was this ratio
between what the adversary knew in the
denominator versus for a given s right
and then what the adversary can
maximally learn given X hat and then
your rate or a log of that and scaling
by a factor all right so here's my
result basically the key idea is as
follows all these measures are Lipschitz
in the distribution of the data XS okay
that's the first thing I prove right and
then so for example for leakage there is
this Lipschitz result locally Lipchitz I
have to be very careful locally Lipchitz
so well these are these are measures
that have log and stuff in them and so
you can't really have Lipschitz
everywhere locally Lipchitz means in a
boundary interval your Lipschitz okay
and the boundary interval is basically
assuming that we have enough samples
that whatever we estimate is close
enough I'll make that clear in a moment
so the second result we use is a
result on what's the the bounds on the
best plugin estimator relative to the
actual distribution so the bonds depend
on I mean these are all large deviations
ricardus retreats with with probability
one - no - right at least 1 - beta so X
and s is really your data set so it
depends on the jar the cardinalities of
both of them and then 1 or 1 over square
root of n is basically how it's going
with the number of sounds
so you put this together with this to
get the following feel so the key ideas
here are always the same whatever
measure I use it's a local lippy anity
and a large deviations in it so what am
I saying here if you give me a dataset
with n samples and I estimate the
empirical distribution as P hat n right
from n iid samples drawn from this P
then we probably at least 1 minus beta
you give me any privacy mechanism W the
leakage measure that I can delete for
this W the leakage that I can give you
from this estimate is bounded away from
the actually catch if I knew P by this
yeah by this term so this term obviously
includes alpha it includes explicitly
this s because s is what we want to keep
secret and then the cardinality of the
entire input which is X and s and then 1
over square root
this is a negative result wait
is it a negative result I mean it's it's
saying yeah they saying is exactly what
the cost is going to be for you Carnell
TFS might not be a tax yes it is minus
log beta okay so this is a great
question okay so if if you wanted really
if you wanted beta to be 10 to the minus
7 by you nodding you why are you shaking
your head R that means 1 minus 10 to the
minus 7 probabilistic guarantee that's
pretty high but if you had an image or
and you still went into a very high
feature space this could potentially be
much larger than 7 so I really think
this is the dominant term huh yeah that
is like the cardinality of the alphabet
is a feature of using the but you know
estimator yes also I mean it's worth
highlighting mm along the top because
that's kind of the basis the dynamics
here like whether the song is that you
see how these metrics vary on their
small perturbations and that
approximation guarantee in terms of
total variation you could try to divide
that using other customers yes you'd
only do better only do better
again sorry this is just when we're
looking at them W here is like the the
margin yeah the Met is the randomize
process yes correct that fixed so when
alpha goes to infinity that's a special
case of this this is just this alpha
just is coming from choosing any okay
this is I should have put up what L
alpha is it's a measure
hey when alpha goes to infinity that
Lipschitz constant should be zero right
it's not supposed to depend on the input
distribution that's when alpha goes to
infinity this is just the ratio of the
probability of error given something
divided by the original probability
event Express that will also show up
later but
all right sorry it's all I'm all I'm
saying is it's sort of addresses your
question if maybe you didn't even know
on the estimate maximal leakage you want
it estimate infinity leakage but for
this particular secret s the key you
want to hide this is the cost of its
yeah it's just the other moto mutual
information of order infinity
multiplicative increase in the
probability of guessing correct I can do
this for else if soon and then I can do
it for maximum alpha leak okay now it's
very interesting these are really you
know this is a remoter mutual
information this is substantial
information this is the maximum a remote
Owen sip see something very strange
happens because these measures are
slightly different right so this is what
you get for Simpson for sips in this is
the lip sanity behavior
so you estimate sips in at two de for
two different input distributions it
really depends on the probability of the
least likely symbol of the secret this
is the sensitive ear okay and then when
you do this in the maximal case it's
similar but now the alphabet size of s
also comes into play because of the way
you're taking this maximum when you work
out the details you have no choice but
so if s was binary this is not a big
cost but if F s becomes large this can
become problematic
so yes Oh max here is not shooting the
alphabet s alpha codes infinity is
maximum leakage do I have a constraint
on the alphabet size of s yeah they mean
they're all discrete at this point but
if alpha was Infinite well if after to
infinity this becomes 4 times absolute
value cardinality of s divided by M s
actually no no no no no so this is a
great great question great question what
we're looking at here is LS 2 X hat
you're hiding all possible functions of
the secret not LX 2x I call it
distribution on secret and what is Q
distribution on Q is yes Q is a so you
can say that X and s are jointly
distributed rescue so if I had to design
a mechanism I still will use my ground
truth to design the mechanism so you
assume you're doing this on a training
data set so you have X and s the thing I
was trying to see fit I remember that
max leakage as Aaron defined it as is
independent of a cute cup of the in the
distribution on X and I was wondering if
that sort of shows up but I guess it
doesn't
so because it's from s to X hat what's
coming in here is when I'm estimating so
the I wish I had my I should have put
those slides up
what Simpson does is the following sips
in is a sort of a centroid of the
conditional distributions so how well
you estimate the least likely
how it's very crucial to estimating this
measurement and that is why that appears
it doesn't appear in our moto and it's
very weird because I remote to sort of
average is that is this like is it is
this in the worst case over q1 and q2
condition on the sides best not
conditional but for a given size of s is
this like are these bounds actually
tight I think you should be careful
about that I think these are actually
tight in the sense because if I'm doing
locally Lipchitz pretty much q1 and q2
are assumed to be close enough to each
other that n is that I can hopefully
estimate so that another way to put it
is we assume that the data set is such
that the least likely symbol can be
estimated I have enough this is not
right this is this is not minimax
deviations for this lemma for this
vicious but there in simple binary cases
we get to recover some of the constants
but is it tight in general like
especially in terms of the dependence on
the size of the alphabet I'm not sure we
know that at least with this result of
wiseman this is what we can get I think
there are much better estimators you can
put in before using the large deviations
it just tells you about the small
perturbations of the underlying things
so I don't so if the question is gonna
get a better constant or something like
that I'm in general I don't like or we
can come up with simple examples for
this bound batches but you find in that
example like some binary channel
I think we have that in the paper so
this yeah yeah yeah thanks
so this is the ultimate the the idea
behind this as it is really locally
Lipchitz so how well we capture those
constants depends on what range we look
at etcetera all right so just just to be
very clear this is alpha strictly
greater than one should have that right
up front so you can't do this for mutual
information you have you'd have a login
in the numerator and so the basic proof
ideas are certainly this is where we
start with their remote oh you are using
this generalized mean inequalities
because these are norms right there any
measures and then you use all these cute
little inequalities to do the boundary
so I should have put one more theorem
which went to the result on this but
that's not there but you plug that in
and you get the same result in charge
which is 2012 he has something very
close to this one on minimax estimators
before before you do the minimax or
problem something like this let's say
you take the KL distance between two
distributions and you try to relate it
under let's say two focal differential
privacy to the total variation distance
between them and it seems to me that
it's very very related to this did you
yeah I'm sorry once you get total
variation between distribution yeah I
mean he's looking he uses kale for doing
a hypothesis test right and then he does
total variation yeah but this so okay
just the reason I clarify is there are
only two elements to this bound right I
mean this we're saying we're in a regime
where you know that these two are living
in some bounded space they're not so far
away from each other right then how
exactly these constants tell me how the
function of that behaves and then I'm
just probably you can take your favorite
best plug and play estimator I did he do
something more precisely in MA did you
use a better plugin estimator or did he
do something this kale works differently
from some of these measures
any other questions
thank you so mostly done
thanks for coming and we're open to all
kinds of comments feedback constructive
criticism and so on for all people's one
which are creationist doesn't